tantas carpas en el horizonte como el
ojo puede ver en este campamento de
refugiados provisional en la aldea de
cada provincia y hassan de 41 años
habita este pequeño refugio de concreto
junto con sus seis hijos él y su familia
ahora también tienen que preocuparse por
el coronavirus
vivimos en un campamento todos
abarrotados si alguien habla con su
familia todos los vecinos pueden
escuchar a uno de mis familiares de
contagio de kobe 19 hace un tiempo y yo
estoy muy asustado porque tengo una
enfermedad preexistente
esta historia se repite en otros
refugios del campamento aquí tomar una
ducha o incluso lavarse las manos es un
lujo y el distanciamiento social es
imposible de acuerdo con naciones unidas
el número de casos de kobe 19 en el
nororiente de siria es seis veces mayor
de lo que era hace un mes el instituto
médico de it le respondió a la pandemia
de coronavirus en los campamentos del
norte de varias formas trabajando en
campañas de concientización en
cooperación con varias organizaciones
disponiendo de cuatro líneas de atención
para responder a las inquietudes de los
ciudadanos y trabajando para disponer de
ambulancias y centros de 40 en after
market sin embargo esto está lejos de
ser suficiente para disminuir la curva
de contagios en síria en estos
campamentos abarrotados de gente es más
probable que la propagación del virus
sea más rápida que no
países aquí los trabajadores de la salud
están en alerta ante una potencial
catástrofe sanitaria